Peggy 18
hi everyone I'm Roland lesterland the
game director for Just Cause 3 and
welcome to the beautiful Mediterranean
island chain of Medici as Rico Rodriguez
you'll explore all 400 square miles of
this vast open world right now let's
just jump straight into the freefall
towards the town of album at Avalanche
Studios we love building huge sandbox
worlds and everything you see here on
the screen you can travel to the hills
the mountains the beaches you name it
what you see you can go straight to it
the story behind Medici is that it's
being held under the brutal control of
the dictator general Diavolo as you can
see his domineering presence can be felt
throughout all the towns and the
villages inspiring a revolution to free
the people is no simple task for any
ordinary citizen but Rico is no ordinary
person with his unique tools of
destruction and large arsenal of
weaponry it's entirely up to you on how
you want to free the people it can all
start with toppling one of the classic
symbols of general D revellers rule
here we'll see Rico using the physics of
the world and his new multi tethers to
force D Ravello statue into inflicting
damage upon itself
alright so with the statue destroyed and
Dieruff ellos tyrannous grip on the town
of Alba no longer quite so tight let's
have a look at Rico's new upgraded
grapple as with JC toon traversals very
much at the heart of the experience
Medici is packed with activities
challenges and opportunities for
creative destruction here we can see one
of Dieruff ellos propaganda spouting
speakers so let's make quick work of it
and tear it down using these tethers
Rico is able to rip chaos objects like
this from their supports as you destroy
these pieces of propaganda you further
weaken deal Velas influence over the
area gas stations were so much fun in JC
- we decided that we wanted to take them
out of the core chaos progression system
and just allow players to destroy them
as many times as they want and our
physics play to our favor as a trained
reaction kicks off then the whole place
goes up
let's take advantage of Rico's brand-new
wingsuit which completes Rico's set of
aerial abilities alongside the grapple
and parachute
as you can see here the sense of speed
with the wingsuit deployed is
unparalleled with the right terrain we
can cover huge distances very quickly
just as with the parachute Rico can use
his grapple to pull himself along thus
giving them an additional speed boost
and have tons of fun doing it
let's apply a little out-of-the-box
thinking with one of the many airborne
vehicles in the game Nikko can fly
anything so hijacking this jet really
isn't an issue and this might be a
multi-million dollar military plane but
in Rico's hands it's a very big
inexpensive bullet all right so we've
blown up the refinery and we've seen the
Cascade of destruction now let's take to
the roads in a souped up sports car Just
Cause 3 they're over 80 different air
land and sea vehicles for you to drive
crash do whatever you want with our
driving model has been completely
overhauled since Jessica's to giving
players more control over the vehicles
themselves as well as increasing their
destructibility of course there are
numerous race challenges for you to play
that will allow you to unlock vehicle
based mods to improve your rise
we're not a racing game so going
off-road in our world can be lots of fun
our state-of-the-art destruction extends
even to vegetation so if you're under
heat trying to get away from people you
can plow through fields of sunflowers
and lavender fields even through bushes
and trees
don't stop here thought give you an
opportunity to blow up something truly
massive
I guess we're going man versus bridge
with our super-powerful hydra missiles
and see what kind of damage we can cause
shooting out the supports will result in
the bridge destroying in tons of
different ones and this means you can
come up with your own great action
moments and that's the core of the
sandbox experience
with the bridge out of commission Rico
can focus on the next objective and to
make that a little easier we've
instituted a new rebel drop system the
rebel drop system allows Rico to order
weapons and vehicles at a moment's
notice
via airdrop this beautiful and peaceful
flight offers us another opportunity to
show off a new feature and that's our
new stunting system so we moved away
from the specific authored points on
vehicles from JC - and allowed the
player total freedom on top so if you
jump out onto the plane you can actually
walk around the plane wings themselves
and of course the plane itself can be
used as a means of destruction maybe we
should get off the plane first
let's swap out wings for wheels and take
a motorbike for the remainder of our
journey and while it's nice to weave
along meta cheese roads with the wind in
our face it is inevitable that the other
fellows men will catch up you can do
combat directly from the bite and
eventually defeating deer bellows
military and here we are at another of
the generals huge military facilities
let's put all Rico's abilities and tools
to the test and take down vigil ater
suits huge communications fires and
satellite dish and [ __ ] the generals
hold on Scirocco